[Gelächter]
merkel war gestern die Christdemokraten
wollen in Zukunft wieder eine andere
Partei sein im Entwurf des
Grundsatzprogramms wird aufgeräumt eine
strengere Asylpolitik eine mögliche
Rückkehr zur Atomkraft ein Bekenntnis
zur deutschen Heimat und leidkultur ein
Begriff den Friedrich märz im Jahr 2000
prägte macht die Union damit eine Rolle
rückwärts oder eben genau vorwärts das
vierte Programm in der Parteigeschichte
soll die Union wieder regierungsfähig
machen Islam Atomkraft Rente die CDU und
die neue leidkultur unser Thema
jetzt
phönixrunde herzlich Willkommen bei uns
ich darf ihn meine Gäste vorstellen ich
begrüße Torsten frei erster
parlamentarischer Geschäftsführer der
CDU CSU Bundestagsfraktion herzlich
willkommen Anton Hofreiter Mitglied des
Bundestages fürbündnis 90 die Grünen und
Vorsitzer des des europaausschusses Eva
Quadbeck ist bei uns sie ist
Chefredakteurin und Leiterin des
Hauptstadtbüros des redaktionsnetwerk
Netzwerks Deutschland rnd ein
Zusammenschluss von über 50
Regionalzeitungen und Jan Hollitzer
Chefredakteur der Thüringer Allgemeinen
ist uns zugeschaltet aus Erfort die Bahn
hat ein bisschen dafür gesorgt dass er
doch nicht hier sein konnte herzlich
willkommen ihn aus Erfurt Herr frei
jetzt wurde dieses Programm gestern
vorgestellt das der Entwurf des
Grundsatzprogramm muss ja dann alles
noch verabschiedet werden als CDU warum
braucht die CDU eine Besinnung auf CDU
pur und neue Grundsätze also zunächst
einmal glaube ich ist es notwendig dass
jede Partei in regelmäßigen Abständen
ihre Grundsätze nicht nur definiert
sondern auch herunterbricht auf die
Aufgaben und Herausforderungen der Zeit
bei uns als Union kam dazu dass
natürlich nach 16 Jahren
Regierungsbeteiligung immer auch die
Gefahr besteht dass man am Ende etwas
inhaltlich ausgelaugt ist deswegen ist
es glaube ich ganz notwendig ähm die
Chance auch der Opposition zu nutzen um
regierungsfähig zu sein und zum dritten
ja wir haben veränderte Zeiten wir haben
veränderte Herausforderungen ich glaube
das ist notwendig deutlich zu machen
wofür wir stehen und das ist dann auch
der Unterschied oder die Antwort auf
Ihre Frage es geht darum wofür steht die
Christdemokratie in Deutschland und
nicht etwa wo ist ein möglicher Koal
Kompromiss das hat man an anderer Stelle
dann zu klären sondern CDU pur heißt
einfach wir wollen deutlich machen wofür
wir stehen in den zentralen Fragen heute
und in den nächsten 10 Jahren jetzt
haben sie ja gesagt 16 Jahre
Regierungsverantwortung ist ja eben auch
16 Jahre angela Merkel ist es gerade der
Bruch mit der Politik von Angela Merkel
weil es gibt ja ganz klare Zeichen dass
sie sich da verändern die die CDU jetzt
wieder regierungsfähig macht nein das
ist kein Bruch sondern das ist die
Tatsache dass wir unsere Grundsätze in
den Herausforderungen der aktuellen Zeit
definieren und entsprechend
ausbuchstabieren und dass jede Zeit Ihre
Herausforderungen und ihre
Herangehensweise hat ähm ist glaube ich
liegt in der Natur der Sache angela
Merkel ist
2018 nicht mehr angetreten als
bundesvorsitzend der CDU und so wie
immer auch schon davor
muss eine Partei dann ohne ihre
Vorsitzende laufen lernen und genau das
haben wir gemacht das deswegen ist es
nicht die entscheidende Kategorie
sondern haben wir glaubwürdige
überzeugende Antworten für die
Herausforderungen der Zeit okay sie
haben jetzt laufen gelernt Frau Quadbeck
ist das jetzt dieses Programm ist das
sozusagen ja neuer Wein in alten sch
Schläuchen denn dieser Begriff
Leitkultur der wurde ja schon 2000 2000
von März eingeführt also ist es jetzt
CDU pur oder März pur was wir da gelesen
haben na ja der Herr märz ist ja im
Moment der Vorsitzende dieser Partei und
er hat seine Handschrift da sehr
deutlich hinterlassen äh es war der
Generalsekretär der seine Handschrift da
mit reingebracht hat und sie haben das
Stichwort leidkultur genannt ich ähm
finde dass das tatsächlich eher eine
Rolle rückwärts als eine
Vorwärtsbewegung ist es ist ja richtig
dass man von den hier zugewanderten
Menschen eine vernünftige Integration
einfordert es aber jetzt mit diesem
alten Kampfbegriff der leidkultur zu tun
die da aus der mtenkiste gezogen wurde
das halte ich nicht für besonders klug
weil äh nun wieder nur über diesen
Begriff kultur diskutiert wird und
überhaupt nicht über die Sache selbst
also welche konkreten Maßnahmen muss man
ergreifen um dann eben die Integration
zu erreichen und vielleicht noch ein
Gedanke es heißt immer unsere leidkultur
das Programm definiert aber überhaupt
nicht wer hinter als wir hinter diesem
uns steht sind es die Schreiber des
Programms ist es die CDU sind es die CDU
Wähler ist es die Mehrheitsgesellschaft
also ich weiß es nicht ich würde mich
jedenfalls in diesem wir nicht unbedingt
integriert fühlen okay dann reden wir
gleich no no mal ausführlich über die
Leitkultur würde aber gerne erstmal die
anderen beiden Herren noch zu Wort
kommen lassen Herr Hofreiter also
Leitkultur Asylverfahren in Drittstaaten
ist ein Punkt über den reden wir
natürlich auch noch Rückkehr zur
Atomkraft mögliche Rückkehr zu
Atomkraftwerk genderverbot was ist für
sie der größte Aufreger wenn Sie das
Grundsatzprogramm gesehen haben für mich
ist da überhaupt kein Aufreger drin in
dem Grundsatzprogramm sondern für mich
ist verblüffend wie man ein Programm
schreiben kann in so schwierigen Zeiten
D so komplett aus der Zeit gefallen
wirkt also wenn wir uns anschauen was
für riesen Herausforderungen wir haben
russland hat die Ukraine angegriffen wir
haben sehen dass die russische
Kriegswirtschaft läuft wie noch mal was
wir sehen die Riesenprobleme im
Südchinesischen Meer wir sehen die
Probleme mit der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
die Deutschland hat wir sehen die
Probleme dass wir nicht genug Halbleiter
produziert bekommen und was wir auch für
die innere Sicherheit brauchen nämlich
Rüstungsindustrie ohne Halbleiter
funktioniert nicht wir sehen die riesen
Probleme mit der klim Krise wir sehen
dass dafür der Staat unglaublich
gefordert ist und auf all das finde ich
überhaupt keine Antworten drin dagegen
bizarre Sachen wie wie z.B leidkultur
ich habe nicht das Gefühl wenn ich mir
die Reden der Union anhöre im Bundestag
insbesondere des bundesvorsitzen dass
ich damit groß was zu tun habe was ich
mir erwarte von Leuten in Deutschland
ist dass sie sich an die Gesetze halten
und dass sie sich ans Grundgesetz halten
also das hätte gereicht ein Bekenntnis Z
Grund zum Grundgesetz aber das ist ja
nicht Leitkultur Kultur ist ja was ganz
anderes also und deshalb finde ich
eigentlich jetzt regen sie sich ja doch
ein bisschen auf nein ich find's einfach
wirklich gefährlich dass wir in
Deutschland im Moment eine Lage haben
dass bei diesen Schwierigkeiten wir
haben die SPD die den Kanzler stellt ich
habe da schon einiges dazu gesagt die in
meinen Augen auch nicht regieren mit
dieser SPD ja aber sie sind trotzdem
nicht auf Höhe der Probleme was ein
riesenprem ist was man auch an dem
peinlichen Verhalten auf dem SPD
Parteitag gesehen hat als mich ich rot
nicht gewählt worden ist und wir haben
die größte Oppositionspartei im moment
de facto die einzige demokratische
Oppositionspartei die auch sozusagen da
völlig rausfällt und sich wirklich in
albernen
kulturkämpfen verstrickt wie z.B ein
genderverbot was die CSU aber auch die
CDU in Hessen die bis vor kurzem so ja
doch eher vernünftig wirkte also und da
frage ich mich so e haben wir keine
anderen Probleme okay also das ist klar
also ich sehe schon sie regen sich eben
doch ein bisschen auf Herr holitzer der
der CDU Vorsitzende März hatte den Plan
2019 hat das glaube ich schon gesagt die
Wählerschaft der AFD zu halbieren die
punktet ja vor allen Dingen in den in
Ostdeutschland wir haben sie auch
eingeladen für diesen Blick weil wir ja
nächstes Jahr auch diese drei Wahlen in
Ostdeutschland haben ist das
Grundsatzprogramm gerade auch mit dieser
Betonung auf auf diesem Begriff auch
Leitkultur ist das die richtige Antwort
um gerade für Ostdeutschland und um die
AFD zu halbieren
wo wir beim Grundsatz sind muss man
sagen also ist mal grundsätzlich die
richtige Antwort dass man sich ein neues
Programm gibt denn so ein richtiges
Profil war bei der CDU ja nicht mehr
wahrnehmbar und jetzt versucht sie im
Prinzip die Mitte neu zu definieren denn
unter Angela Merkel hat man ja irgendwie
alle Themen besetzt die es gab um so
verhindern dass ich andere Parteien in
irgendeine Art und Weise profilieren
können und dabei hat man eben selbst
massiv an Profil verloren und
Bundespolitik wirkt sich ja immer auch
auf Landespolitik aus und genauso schwer
hatten es dann natürlich auch die
Landesverbände in einem sehr scharfen
profilommen zu werden ob das jetzt
allerdings gelingt mit Blick auf die
Landtagswahlen die anstehen auch hier in
Thüringen und wie man dieses Programm
vermitteln kann das muss man sehen ganz
scharfen Blick auf Thüringen den ich
natürlich habe wo die CDU in der
Opposition ist und es sehr schwer hat
weil sie der rotrotgrünen Regierung
immer zu Mehrheiten verschaff schaffen
muss demonstriert sie jetzt
Handlungsfähigkeit oder auch
Unabhängigkeit indem sie Gesetze mit der
AFD und FDP gegen die Regierungsmehrheit
durchbringt also von von daher denke ich
ist es der richtige und notwendige
Schritt gewesen sich da einen neuen
Grundsatz und sich an die Realität
anzupassen auf die Eingangsfrage
vielleicht es ist eine Rolle rückwärts
als auch eine Rolle vorwärts würde ich
sagen okay Frau sie haben ja geschrieben
nach dem Wahlsieg von Boris rein
Ministerpräsident in Hessen haben sie
gesagt der hat gezeigt dass die CDU mit
Männern der Mitte irgendwie Wahlerfolge
machen verbuchen kann also Henrik wüst
in nordrin-westfalen Kai Wegner in
Berlin Daniel Günther in schleswig-
Holstein ist das jetzt dieses Programm
ein Programm für diese Männer oder doch
irgendwie für eine andere Partei ja so
ganz entschieden ist es nicht am Anfang
des Programms lese ich dass die CDU sich
als Volkspartei der Mitte definiert und
sie wäre auch wirklich klug beraten sich
nicht nur nur so zu definieren sondern
das eben auch in den Details
auszubuchstabieren und dann sind da aber
eben auch so Dinge drin wie die
leidkultur oder dass man sich von diesem
doch längst irgendwie ausdiskutierten
Satz dass der Islam auch zu Deutschland
gehöre wieder verabschiedet und sagt
dass Muslime die und dann kommt wieder
dieses
unsere Werte teilen zu Deutschland
gehören also da frage ich mich warum man
das macht und
das hat auch nicht so viel damit zu tun
dass man da dann besonders gut
Grundsätze
den Menschen ver Mel die eine Partei hat
sondern das gibt einfach nur polemischen
Diskussionsstoff das halte ich nicht für
klüg und genau diese Männer der Mitte
die ich beschrieben habe die vermeiden
nämlich genau das und deshalb verstehe
ich nicht warum die CDU Führung in
Berlin das tut dann fragen wir die CDU
Herr frei warum macht man also das in
dem es heißt in dem Programm Muslime die
unsere Werte teilen gehören zu
Deutschland warum schreiben Sie das so
auf oder warum wird so also zunächst mal
ich weiß gar nicht wo ich anfangen soll
bei dem was ich hier in dieser Runde
alles höre Blei wir mal dai Blei wir mal
bei dieser bei dieser frageem schwierig
ist die das bisher Gesagte nicht richtig
einzuordchf aber also ich finde dieser
Satz ist doch eine pure
Selbstverständlichkeit also diejenigen
die unsere Werte teilen das sind
insbesondere auch die Werte unseres
Grundgesetzes und da gehört die Würde
des Einzelnen dazu da gehört die
Gleichberechtigung von Mann und Frau
dazu da gehört der Respekt vor unserem
Rechtssystem dazu die gehören
selbstverständlich zu unserer
Gesellschaft wenn Sie
aber man knte auch schreiben Katholiken
die unsere Werte wer gehört nicht dazu
dann sind es beispielsweise diejenigen
die die chararia in Deutschland anwenden
möchten dann sind es diejenigen die
glauben dass der Friedensrichter vor dem
Rechtssystem in Deutschland
gilt die
Trennung in Deutschland unter einen
generalverdach nein doch gerade nicht
sondern dieser Satz sagt doch Muslime es
leben 6 Millionen Muslime bei uns in
Deutschland die diese Werte teilen mhm
die gehören selbstverständlich zu
unserer Gesellschaft und zu unserem stat
was ist denn mit Christen die unsere
Werte nicht teilen z.B
Reichsbürger ich wüsste jetzt allerdings
nicht dass es dass es Christen gibt die
grundsätzlich die Trennung von Staat und
Kirche in Frage stellen und glauben dass
die Gesetze der Bibel über den Gesetzen
des Staates sind also das sind doch
eigentlich Selbstverständlichkeiten ich
find's ja komisch Frau Quadbeck sie
haben das Thema angesprochen ich meine
wer sind denn diejenigen die solche
Dinge diskutieren die über solche Sachen
wie Leitkultur was ja eigentlich auch
nur eine Selbstverständlichkeit ist
diskutieren anstatt dass sie sich mit
den Kerninhalten des Programmes
auseinandersetzen das was man selber tut
darf man doch anderen nicht vorwerfen ja
ich habe kritisiert dass die CDU hier
den Versuch unternimmt
Integrationsprobleme Weg zu definieren
anstatt sie konkret auszubuchstabieren
in ihrem Grundsatzprogramm natürlich ist
es eine Selbstverständlichkeit dass
die Menschen zu uns gehören die unsere
Werte teilen im Sinne von wenn sie es
jetzt so
definieren Grund dass dass sie auf dem
Grundgesetz stehen ja aber warum
schreiben Sie es dann nicht so rein dann
wäre doch dann hätten sie sich diese
Debatte die wir jetzt führen erspart und
wir würden
vielleicht fen diese deten gar nicht
davon bin ich wirklich überzeugt und ich
meine vielleicht Herr Hofreiter ein Satz
zu ihnen ihnen muss das Programm ja
nicht gefallen also wenn ich mir die
vergangenen Parteitage von SPD und
Grünen anschaue habe ich das Gefühl dass
diese beiden Regierungsparteien in einer
anderen Welt leben wir machen doch
gerade Vorschläge im Bereich der außen
und Sicherheitspolitik der Stärkung der
Bundeswehr wie wir uns behaupten in
einer sich dramatisch verändernden Welt
wir haben ein Konzept wie man die
migrationsherausforderungen bewältigen
kann das wäre mir von keiner anderen
Partei in Deutschland bekannt und so
könnte ich genauso weitermachen was ist
denn ihre Antwort darauf dass
Deutschland das einzige Industrieland
ist das eine schrumpfende Wirtschaft ja
bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei dir ich
würde gerne noch mal einmal über diesen
Begriff leitkulturen und fragen was das
für das Zusammenleben mit Muslim in
unserem Land bedeutet her Hofreiter wenn
Sie das Hören es gibt ja Menschen das
ist ja so es gibt ja auch Menschen die
an die Friedensrichter glauben es gibt
Probleme auch mit mit klarenkriminalität
mit all diesen Sachen ist es da nicht
richtig dass die CDU da ja einen klaren
Punkt hat und sagt ja wir wollen noch
mal daran erinnern dass die Menschen
auch ein Bekenntnis zu unserem
Grundgesetz abgeben sollen ja ich bin
absolut dafür das habe ich ja gesagt und
das hat ja auch Frau KBE gesagt
selbstverständlich müssen die Leute die
hier bei uns leben und zwar egal wo sie
herkommen sich an unsere Gesetze und ans
Grundgesetz halten aber die Union ist ja
nicht doof die weiß ja auch ganz genau
dass leidkultur was anders ist als wie
in Bekenntnis zum Grundgesetz und ich
teile z.B die Werte von Herrn märz nicht
und zwar ganz dezitiert teile ich die
Werte von Herrn märz nicht ich finde das
was er in seinen bundestagsreden sagt
zum großen Teil falsch aber das ist
völlig okay weil wir leben nämlich in
einer pluralen Demokratie und wenn man
sozusagen das aufschreiben will dass wir
der Meinung ist dass die Menschen sich
ans Grundgesetz halten soll und an die
Gesetze halten soll was es eine
Selbstverständlichkeit ist und wobei der
Integration auch manches schief gegangen
ist und wo wir wir haben du Hus auch
Christen bei uns im Land die glauben
dass die Bibel sozusagen überm
Grundgesetz steht aber das nur am Rande
darum geht's ja hier im Kern gar nicht
dann soll man das halt so hinschreiben
aber man hat sich glaube ich bewusst für
etwas anderes entschieden und dieses
bewusst für etwas anderes zu entscheiden
einen extrem doppeldeutigen Begriff wie
Leitkultur zu verwenden der völlig
interpretationsoffen ist und dann auch
unsere ja der ist völlig
interpretationsoffen der ist völlig
interpretationsoffen und dann auch noch
unsere Werte zu schreiben wo völlig
unklar ist in dem Programm was mit uns
gemeint ist die Werte von Herrn märz und
von ihnen die Werte sozusagen von den
CDU Mitgliedern die Werte
von den demokratisch gesindten
abgeordnet im Deutschen Bundestag oder
die christlichen Werte weil die Partei
sich ja klar also ich bin z.B ungläubig
also ich weiß gar nicht ob ich damit
gemint bin oder ob ich eigentlich
rausdefiniert werden soll also ich
empfinde mich
sozusagen als rausdefiniert aus der
Gesellschaft und ich glaub vielen Leuten
gibt so und wenn Sie das Schreiben
würden was sie jetzt gesagt haben g
darüber überhaupt keine Diskussion bloß
sagen ja ist selbstverständlich kusion g
nicht sie sind bewusst unscharf Herr
holitzer wie wie empfinden Sie diesen
Begriff mit der leidkultur was würden
Sie sagen ist das ein Punkt der eher
ausgrenzt oder wo man sagt ja wir wir
bekennen uns einfach ganz klar zu dem ja
dass wir sagen die Menschen die
hierherkommen die sollen auch ein
Bekenntnis eben
abgeben die Werte Diskussion führen wir
ja im Prinzip schon relativ lang dass
ich sie haben sie eben angesprochen auch
es betrifft ja nicht nur eingewanderte
Menschen sondern auch Menschen Menschen
die leben und das System Ableben
Reichsbürger haben sie eben genannt das
diese Diskussion führen wir lange
Leitkultur ist in der Tat etwas weit
gefasst aber ich glaube auch nicht dass
Herr Hofreiter jetzt unbedingt das
Klientel zählt was die CDU erreichen
will in gewissen Bevölkerungsgruppen
wird glaube ich eine intensivere
Wertediskussion geführt als als in
anderen und von
daher insgesamt muss man doch
feststellen dass die seit dem Auftauchen
oder Auftreten der AFD als politischen
Akteur die Rhetorik insgesamt
populistischer und drastischer geworden
ist auch wenn dieser Begriff leidkultur
natürlich ein bisschen älter ist aber er
trifft irgendwie den Kern der
öffentlichen gesellschaftlichen aber
auch politischen Debatte in Landtagen im
bundestagen und so weiter mhm wie was
sagen sie zu dem Vorwurf her frei dass
es ja ein
populistischer Programmpunkt ist oder
ein populistischer Begriff und dass sie
damit sozusagen auch in Richtung ja
Wähler der AFD schielen nein also mit
dem Begriff Populismus im Zusammenhang
mit diesem grundsatzprogrammentwurf kann
ich gar nichts anfangen es ist ein
Programmentwurf der sehr klar ist in den
Formulierungen der klar macht wofür wir
stehen und das war ja auch ihre
Eingangsfrage es geht um CDU pur wir
schauen nicht darauf welche Auswirkungen
hat es auf die AFD wie gut gefällt es
den Grünen
Poli wollte die werschft
hallussfig wir an die SPD darum geht's
gerade nicht sondern es geht darum aus
uns heraus aus unseren Werten abgeleitet
dem christlichen Bild von Menschen und
unseren Grundsätzen auszubuchstabieren
was das bei den einzelnen Themen
bedeutet und jetzt will ich noch einen
Satz dazu sagen also Friedrich März hat
diesen Satz gesagt aber als er ihn
gesagt hat haben wir noch regiert und
eine populistische eine
rechtspopulistische Partei wie die AFD
zu halbieren das kann man machen wenn
man eine gute Regierungspolitik macht
wir sind jetzt in der Opposition und
haben diese Möglichkeiten leider nicht
wir wissen dass die AFD auch deshalb so
stark ist weil die Ampel eine Politik
macht mit der viele Menschen in
Deutschland nicht einverstanden sind 75%
lehnen die Politik der Ampel ab ja aber
dann könnte man ja auch sagen wenn Sie
die Ampel ablehnen dann sehen Sie in der
CDU eine Alternative und gehen halt eben
dain da dran arbeiten wir jeden Tag und
gerade heute haben wir wieder Umfragen
bekommen die uns wachsend gezeigt haben
im Gegensatz zu den anderen Parteien im
Bundestag also insofern sind wir auf dem
richtigen Weg aber wir haben noch eine
Wegstrecke vor uns und ein wesentlicher
Punkt auf dieser Wegstrecke ist
natürlich die programmatische Erneuerung
und damit verbunden auch das
Grundsatzprogramm angesoler weil der hat
ein bisschen Nachteil weil da
zugeschaltet ist deshalb würde ich sie
gerade gern ihn noch mal das Wort geben
weil sie gerne dazu was sagen würden
also das jetzt nur auf die el Regierung
zu schieben ist glaube ich ein
bisschen preiswert sagt man da denn ich
glaube viele Dinge die wir momentan
erleben rühren natürlich auch aus einer
gescheiderten
Integrationspolitik Migrationspolitik
auch unter CDU Führung her die wir lange
Zeit erlebt haben und noch mal also es
ist richtig dass sie sich da ein neues
Grundsatzprogramm geben aber es ist
natürlich erstm ein absolutes
versprechen und irgendwie auch eine
Wette auf die Zukunft dass es ankommt
und man muss sehen wenn sie wieder in
Regierungsverantwortung kommen kriegen
sie es tatsächlich hin sie das besser
mit den Drittstaaten in sie sagen sie
haben einen Plan aber es geht ja um die
Durchsetzungsfähigkeit auch die
Durchsetzungsfähigkeit oder oder das das
Einhalten rechtsstaatlicher Prinzipien
womit wir jetzt ja schon große Probleme
haben also da ist noch ein großes
Fragezeichen dahinter also angesichts
der sage ich mal wirklich schlechten
Performance der Ampel und der schlechten
Umfragewerte der Ampel müsste die Union
aus meiner Sicht viel mehr in den
Umfragen durch die Decke gehen und ich
sehe die Union in dem strategischen
Dilemma auch mit diesem
Grundsatzprogramm auf der einen Seite
verabschieden sie sich so ein wenig von
Merkels Alter Mitte weil sie sagen CDU
pur und das war Merkel ja nie sie war ja
immer eine Pragmatikerin der Macht und
jetzt geht man auch stärker wieder auf
das parteipolitische rückt die Partei
auch ein wenig nach rechts das ist
nichts ungewöhnliches das Parteien das
in der CDU Entschuldigung in der
Opposition tun nur bei der CDU ist das
Problem dass rechts eben die AFD steht
und die them die sie in Teilen auch
bedienen ich will gar nicht sagen
populistisch Themen wie
Integration wie Grenzschutz wie Fragen
der Zuwanderung die bedient die AFD
immer in einer radikalen Art und Weise
und viele ja heimatlose konservative die
sie in der merkelzeit verloren haben die
sind längst da angekommen und die
kriegen sie mit einem Begriff wie leid
Kultur nicht zurück aber Merkels frühere
Mitte sie ab mit diesem Begriff und das
ist das strategische Dilemma in dem die
UN also zunächst mal Frau Quadbeck muss
man ja sehen kennen Sie eine zweite
Partei in Europa christdemokratische
Partei die ähnlich erfolgreich ist wie
die CDU das gibt es nicht also wenn man
das Parteienspektrum in Europa mal
anschaut da muss man sagen sind wir sehr
erfolgreich und der zweite Punkt ist der
also ich glaube nicht dass man
erfolgreich ist wenn man Themen die in
den Augen der Bevölkerung von zentraler
Bedeutung sind wie beispielsweise die
Migrationspolitik einfach nicht benennt
ich sag nicht dass sie es nicht benennen
sollen ich sag nur dass sie es nicht mit
dem Begriff Leitkultur überstöpben
sollen son das Thema Leitkultur steht wo
ganz anders Grundsatzprogramm ja das das
steht aber in dem Zusammenhang sondern
dass sie sondern dass sie
sagen was sie konkret
an Integrationspolitik machen wollen ja
Integrationspolitik ist in Ordnung aber
das hat auch etwas mit der Frage der
Quantität zu tun also Deutschland hat
natürlich eine gewaltige integrations
oder migrationsherausforderung in der
Vergangenheit erlebt und wir sehen eben
dass ab einem bestimmten Punkt
Integration häufig nicht mehr
funktioniert wenn Sie heute in sprach
oder Integrationskurs wollen dann warten
Sie ein Jahr drauf das ist der Punkt und
zwar nicht weil das Geld fehlt sondern
weil die Lehrerin und Lehrer fehlen also
ist es richtig Herr Hofreiter dass das
Thema Migration so zentral natürlich
gestellt sehen Sie das auch als einen
Punkt wo man sagt das ist das Kurs
wollen dann warten Sie ein Jahr drauf
das ist der Punkt und zwar nicht weil
das Geld fehlt sondern weil die
lehrerinen und Lehrer fehlen also ist es
richtig Herr Hofreiter dass das Thema
Migration so zentral natürlich gestellt
sehen Sie das auch als einen Punkt wo
man sagt das ist das ja woran sich
letztendlich dann auch Wähler
entscheiden zu welcher Partei sie gehen
die CDU möchte gerne das Asylverfahren
in sicheren Drittstaaten abgewickelt
werden dass also im Menschen hierhkommen
über deren Asylverfahren schon
entschieden ist anstatt dass sie hier
sehr lange sind und nicht arbeiten macht
das nicht irgendwo Sinn ich halte es
ehrlich gesagt für komplett naiv was
sich die naiv was sich die Union
davorstellt weil m das wird halt alles
nicht funktionieren ich habe z.B auf der
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz mit Leuten
aus subsahara Afrika gesprochen und die
haben gesagt ja es stimmt ihr habt Recht
aus rechtsstaatlichen Gründen müssten
wir z.B die Leute
zurücknehmen aber schaut mal wie
schwierig unsere Handelsverträge sind
schaut mal was uns china bietet was ihr
uns bietet und dann schaut mal wie hoch
der Anteil für unsere Ökonomie ist was
die Menschen die bei euch arbeiten zu
uns schicken und deshalb nehmen wir die
Leute einfach nicht zurück und ihr könnt
euch auf den Kopf stellen dann könnte
Einschluss ja auch sein dass die
Menschen weniger Geld bekommen um es
nach da hinzuschicken ja die schicken
aber nicht das Geld dahin sozusagen was
sie als Sozialleistung kriegen sondern
die schicken das Geld dahin was sie
arbeiten weil nämlich was komplett
übersehen wird in dieser ganzen Debatte
ist wir haben nicht nur Fachkräftemangel
wir haben inzwischen Arbeitskräftemangel
wenn ich in Süddeutschland unterwegs bin
da habe ich Mengen gaststädten die sagen
ja Sie müssen frühzeitig schließen weil
sie niemand mehr finden und der
Wettbewerb um Fachkräfte ist zentral für
unseren Wohlstand und diese
Debatte ist das ein ploer für eine ein
eine eine Zuwanderung ohne Begrenzung
nein das ist überhaupt kein l sondern
erstmal für ein nüchternes anerkennen
wie die Realitäten sind wissen Sie also
ein Großteil der Leute die zu uns kommen
kommen aus Afghanistan kommen aus im
Irak kommen aus Syrien und auch aus der
Türkei und der Erdogan dann stellen Sie
sich mal so eine Familie vor den
Afghanistan sit unter den
Lebensbedingungen der Taliban und dann
hört sie die Union schlägt vor wenn sie
es überhaupt mitkriegen es soll
sozusagen für die Zeit des
Asylverfahrens
kein das Geld also die Sozialleistung
soll nicht mehr in Geld sondern in als
Bezahlkarte ausgezahlt werden und dann
sagt die Famil ja dann dann kann ich mir
jetzt vorstellen unter den
Lebensbedingungen der Taliban zu leben
das ist doch komplett bizarr oder
Menschen die sozusagen den volterkeller
Syriens kommen sind also das ist einfach
eine völlig naive bizarre Vorstellung
dafür warum Menschen flüchten und ich
habe vor kurzem sozusagen warum flüchten
sie denn alle nach Deutschland oder die
allermeisten davon die Frage müs sie do
beantw kan man ihnen auch beantworten
der Hauptgrund sozusagen ist weil sie D
hier Verwandschaft haben und der zweite
Grund ist weil unsere Wirtschaft im
Verhältnis sehr gut ist wen man hier
Arbeit findet wenn man sie nicht legal
findet findet man schwarz weil nämlich
sozusagen die Nachfrage nach auch
ungelernten Arbeitskräften bei uns
entsprechend hoch ist und deshalb da
fragen Sie doch mal an bcker fragen Sie
doch mal an Metzger fragen Sie doch mal
an gastwird insbesondere in
Süddeutschland was der braucht der
braucht Arbeitskräfte und deshalb
sozusagen ja dann reden Sie mit den
Leuten und deshalb flüchten die Leute
sozusagen überwiegend nach Deutschland
nein sie FL deshalb nach Deutschland
weil wir den erleichterten Familien
Nachzug haben weil wir die höchsten
Sozialleistungen haben und weil es im
Prinzip so ist dass wer es einmal nach
Deutschland geschafft hat auch hier
bleiben kann Rückführungen finden
praktisch nicht mehr statt und das sind
die wesentlichen Gründe nicht warum die
Menschen ihre Herkunftsländer verlassen
aber warum sie am Ende nach Deutschland
kommen und eben nicht nach Frankreich
oder nach Spanien oder sonst in frei sie
haben im im Sommer hatten sie ja auch
sogar zur Diskussion gestellt dass wir
den Artikel 16 des Grundgesetzes ist
nämlich das Recht auf Asyl dass wir
darüber nachdenken sollen das findet
sich in ihrem Programm jetzt aber nicht
also die CDU hält an dem individuellen
Recht auf Asyl fest ist das ja trotzdem
ist das was ich vorgeschlagen habe eins
zu eins im Programm umgesetzt ähm es ist
nicht entscheidend der Artikel 16A des
Grundgesetzes weil der heute nur für
etwa 0,8% der schutzberechtigten
tatsächlich einschlägig ist seit 1993
ist das Grundgesetz geändert und wer aus
einem Nachbarland
über ein Nachbar Land nach Deutschland
kommt der kann ohnehin nicht auf dieser
Grundlage Asyl beantragen was drin steht
im Programm ist dass sowohl die
Verfahren die Schutzverfahren
in einem sicheren Drittstaat
durchzuführen sind aber genauso auch die
Schutzgewährung wir haben
Individualrechte haben Sie Recht in
unserer Verfassung und auch im
europäischen Recht da steht aber
nirgendwo drin dass das in Deutschland
oder in Europa umzusetzen wäre und das
bedeutet im kesag wden gana versuchen
ein ein Drittstaat zu finden ein
Abkommen zu finden dass die Menschen
dann in gana das da ich habe lediglich
darauf hingewiesen dass gana und Senegal
zwei Länder in Afrika sind die bei uns
sichere Herkunftsstaaten sind und
deswegen zunächst einmal auch die
äußeren Voraussetzungen dafür mitbringen
dass man solche rechtsstaatlichen
Verfahren machen kann und dass man
insbesondere gewährleisten kann dass das
nonrefulmentverbot eingehalten wird aber
das bedeutet im datex sie können sowohl
die Verfahren wie auch die
schutzgewährungen sicheren Drittstaaten
machen und das bedeutet im Umkehrschluss
dass man in der Lage ist Kontingente
ganz besonders schutzbedürftiger
Menschen zu uns zu holen und das F
Kontingente das heißt also eine
Obergrenze weil da darin sind sie auch
nicht ganz klar wir wird nicht benannt
das hi werden konente Gemach ganz klar
dass wir Schutz gewähren aber dass wir
es im Rahmen von Kontingenten machen und
das bedeutet eben auch dass insbesondere
die Städte und Gemeinden wissen was auf
sie zukommt sie können sich darauf
einstellen Integration lässt sich
organisieren ich bin davon überzeugt
dass das das richtige Mittel ist um die
Herausforderungen zu bewtigen was in
Großbritannien gerade schon mehrmals
gescheitertit grßitanen wollte dieses
Abkommen wollte
diesesaganda
nicht erfüllt das muss man schon
differenzierenbeck wie also Thema
Migration Integration ist ein großes
Thema brennt vielen Menschen unter den
Nägeln weil viele weil
Integrationsleistung in vielen Punkten
nicht funktioniert wie sinnvoll oder wie
wie realistisch ist diese Antwort die
die CDU da gibt ich finde es
grundsätzlich aller Mühe wert dass man
guckt ob man solche Verfahren
international machen kann es ist ein
Ansatz es ist ja auch Grundlage davon
war ja das eutürkei Abkommen wo man dann
auch gesagt hat man sendet auch das
Signal in die Welt kommt nicht zu uns
das ist ja das darf man nicht vergessen
es geht nicht nur um die Verfahren
selbst sondern es geht ja auch um das
Signal was sendet Europa aus also dass
ich überhaupt weniger Menschen
auf den Weg machen um nach Deutschland
zu kommen deshalb finde ich ist das
schon der Mühe wert es ist aber in sehr
weiter Ferne dass man tatsächlich
Staaten findet die das humanitär und
nach unseren rechtsstaatlichen
Vorstellungen dann auch dort wirklich
administrieren können das ist
tatsächlich in weiter fne und das ist
keine schnelle Lösung steht in dem
Grundsatzprogramm aber ob man in 10
Jahren so eine Lösung hat Entschuldigung
auf europäischer Ebene gibt's eine
Mehrheit dafür dass es das nicht gibt
heute im geas im gemeinsamen
europäischen Asylsystem das hängt mit
der deutschen Bundesregierung zusammen
ja ich sage ja dass es aller Mühe wert
ist aber dass es trotzdem schwer ist es
zu administrieren aber ist eben ein Weg
müssen no auf paar andere Themen no
gucken alles gut her was denken Sie was
werden die die wahlentscheidenden Themen
sein also in Thüringen auch in den and
ostdeutschen Ländern wo man sagt da
daran entscheidet sich letztendlich wo
die Bürger und Bürgerin ihr Kreuz
machen also wir haben es in den letzten
landagswahl gesehen dass das Thema
Migration natürlich eins der bestimmten
Themen ist und wie das bundespolitisch
diskutiert wird aber wir sehen einfach
die Überforderung der Kommunen da wo es
letztendlich ankommt dass sie sagen wir
können nicht mehr
aufnehmen die Finanzierung war lange
Zeit unklar oder ist immer noch unklar
also wie wird auch die weiter finanziert
ung in den nächsten Jahren sein der
Unterkünfte und der Migranten die hier
ankommen das hat nichts damit zu tun das
ist kein wirklich leidenschaftliches
Engagement vor Ort gibt von Landräten
von Bürgermeistern Oberbürgermeistern
aber dass die Kapazitäten einfach
erschöpft sind und
und wäre dann die richtige Antwort die
Begrenzung wäre dann die richtige
Antwort eine ganz klare
Begrenzung wie es auch immer aussieht
aber auf jeden Fall dieses
Grundsatzprogramm ist eine Abkehr von
wir schaffen das von
von Angela Merkel und wir reden ja von
qualifizierter Zuwanderung die ja nicht
unbedingt nur so stadtgefunden hat und
das ist eins der großen Themen
die sicherlich auch die nächsten
Landtagswahlen bestimmen werden und dazu
kommt natürlich die Finanzierbarkeit des
des des Alltags ne also Energiepreise
ist da ja ein Riesenthema mm kommen wir
mal zum Thema Energie und Klima Herr
Hofreiter wir merken im Moment auch wenn
wir die Klimakonferenz sehen dass es
schwer ist sich da zu einigen und in
vielen Ländern wird über eine Rückkehr
zur Atomkraft diskutiert äh Deutschland
ist da sozusagen eine einsame Insel wo
das nicht so ist ist Deutschland da
inzwischen eigentlich so in so einer
geisterfahrerposition alle anderen haben
da inzwischen die Richtung gewechselt
ich blick da ganz entspannt drauf um
ehrlich zu sein weil nämlich es gibt
viel geredet drüber ich glaube man
sollte sich da an den RWE Boss halten
der da ganz nüchtern drauf blickt und
sagt es lohnt sich ökonomisch von vorne
bis hinten nicht wir sollten uns in
Deutschland die Debatte sparen und
endlich alles dafür tun dass die echten
zukunftsthen das sind seinen Augen die
Erneuerbaren wirklich real umgesetzt
werden und ich meine wenn sie sich das
Europa weiter anschauen also in Finnland
ist jetzt ein neues Atomkraftwerk ans
Netz gegangen das ist seit langem das
erste es ist drei oder vier Mal so teuer
geworden also das W nüchtern me da
kommen sie 15 Cent die Kilowattstunde
aber irgendw muss man ja die CO2 zi ja
aber ich meine man kann den CO2 Preis
also das CO2 nicht reduzieren indem man
einfach komplett teure Verfahren
einsetzt wir brauchen nicht nur wir
brauchen ja nicht nur wir müssen ja
nicht nur sozusagen klimaneutral werden
sondern die Energie muss halt auch
bezahlbar bleiben und wenn sie sich z.B
anschauen Kilowattstunde Photovoltaik
kriegen sie für 2 Cent eine
Kilowattstunde neuebautes Atomkraftwerk
wenn alles super läuft und sie die
ganzen entlagerkosten rausrechnen
kriegen sie das für 10 Cent also das ist
fünfm so teuer wahrscheinlich sozusagen
wenn man nüchtern rechnet im Moment was
im Bau ist eher 15 Cent und des geht es
natürlich nur wenn man das als stat
macht so wie in Frankreich also
letztendlich mit Planwirtschaft kriegen
sie das hin aber mit Marktwirtschaft und
dass das wirklich ökonomisch sich
rechnet kriegen sie das nicht hin weil
es einfach zu teuer ist natürlich ist ja
interessant dass die Z ma
aber es ist nicht unser Weg und ich
halte es auch wirklich für
Geldverschwendung ja her frei ist ja
trotzdem sehr interessant denn gerade
irgendwie unter Angela Merkel nach nach
dem DEB nach der Katastrophe in
Fukushima dann diesen atomausschieg noch
mal verkürzte noch mal schneller machte
sagt sagt jetzt in ihrem Programm
Deutschland kann zur Zeit nicht die auf
die Option Kernkraft verzichten was
heißt zur Zeit also das sind zwei
Aspekte der eine Aspekt ist die Welt hat
sich seit 2011 verändert beispielsweise
durch den russischen Angriffskrieg in
der Ukraine und das russisches Gas nicht
mehr zur Verfügung steht wie wir das
bisher hatten ähm deswegen glaube ich
dass im Frühjahr 2000 ähm also des
vergangenen Jahres ähm die Situation
sich grundlegend geändert hat und es ein
Fehler war die letzten drei am
netzbefindlichen Kernkraftwerke in
dieser Situation abzuschalten damit
weiter zur Verknappung von Energie
beizutragen und die Preise nach oben zu
treiben und der zweite Punkt ist die
Grünen möchten ja am liebsten alles was
irgendwie mit Kernenergie zu tun hat ähm
in Stumpf und Stil sozusagen ausreißen
wir sind beispielsweise der Auffassung
dass man auch Kernreaktoren der vierten
der fünften Generation
nicht ausschließen sollte dass es eine
entsprechende Forschung in Deutschland
geben sollte das halten wir für absolut
richtig und notwendig und ich will
vielleicht ein S sollte staatliche
Gelder reinfließen oder wer aber ich
will ein ja da soll natürlich auch
staatliches Geld reinfließen um
beispielsweise Forschung zu unterstützen
aber ich will ein Punkt an Herrn
Hofreiter sagen der Punkt ist doch der
dass sie Sonne und Wind derzeit und auf
absehbare Zeit nicht jederzeit zur
Verfügung haben mein Wahlkreis liegt in
Süddeutschland im Schwarzwald auf den
Fotovoltaikanlagen liegt Schnee derzeit
und Wind weht kaum also es geht doch
drum wie haben sie gr grundlastfähige
Energie und das bietet mit neuen
Atomkraftwerken hätten ja aber schau was
wie ist denn die Situation heute heute
machen wir das mit Kohleverstromung und
wir kaufen massenhaft Atomenergie aus
dem Ausland ein der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister sagt dass in
saporisia im Kriegsgebiet in der Ukraine
in Kernkraftwerk betrieben wird es
völlig in Ordnung ja wie passt den das
eine zum anderen das ist doch nicht
schlüssig wie sehen Sie das das jetzt
auf einmal diese atomkraftdiskussion W
so eine Rolle spielt und hat irgendeine
Chance aufgenommen zu werden in dem Land
was so stark von der Antiatombewegung
irgendwie geprägt ist wie Deutschland
also ich gebe Herrn frei in dem Punkt
Recht dass es ein Fehler war jetzt
tatsächlich die letzten drei Meiler wie
das der Atomausstieg vorgesehen hat vom
Netz zu nehmen das hätte man nicht tun
sollen einmal als Signal an die
Öffentlichkeit man hätte sagen sollen
hier wir tun wirklich alles um unsere
Energie zu sichern und sicherlich könnte
man auch diese Strommengen noch
gebrauchen zumal sie ja eben nicht mehr
so teuer sind weil die diese Kraftwerke
ja abgeschrieben waren der zweite kann
man hier eine Schubumkehr machen bei der
Atomkraft das glaube ich eher nicht wenn
man sich heute noch mal entscheiden
würde wie machen wir die Klimawende und
gucken noch mal 30 Jahre zurück dann
würde man möglicherweise entscheiden wir
steigen erst aus der Kohlekraft aus und
dann aus der Atomkraft also
möglicherweise würde man diesen Weg
gehen heute also mit dem Wissen von
heute aber ich halte es nicht für
möglich dass wir jetzt sagen und wir
bauen neue Atomkraftwerke wo man
sicherlich forschen sollte ist in der
Kernfusion aber auch das ist ja
Zukunftsmusik wo man nicht sagen kann so
und übermorgen werden wir da unseren
Strom dusus machen können okay
vielleicht sozusagen muss man allerdings
noch eins anmerken wir haben Sanktionen
in Europa gegen nahe zuu alle
Energieformen in Russland mit einer
einzigen Ausnahme wir haben keinerlei
Sanktionen im nuklearen Bereich weil es
keine Energieform gibt wo Europa so
abhängig ist von Russland wie im
nuklearen Bereich wir importieren
sozusagen ganz erhebliche Mengen von
rossatom als Europa und alle Staaten ist
bewusst wie groß die Abhängigkeit ist
und rossatom ist ein Konzern der eng im
industriellen militärischen Komplex
Russlands verbandelt ist also was im
Moment von allen Energieformen am
stärksten dem militärisch industriellen
Komplex in Russland stärkt ist die
Atomkraft deswegen ist es halt auch
sozusagen wieder einfach eine Form von
Naivität unter Ausblendung der Fakten
was wir sozusagen jetzt tun müssten und
da sind wir sehr dafür ist dass wir
endlich sozusagen in Europa eine
stärkere Fertigung von Brennelementen
hinkriegen eine deutlich schnellere
Fertigung von damit wir da unabhängig
werden und das sag ich he grüner aber
das noch
mitit keine Atomkraft ich w ger noch
anderen Punk machen und zwar ich wir
diskutieren jetzt darüber was steht aber
ich würde auch ganz gerne sagen was
nicht drin steht denn ich halte es als
ein absolutes Versäumnis dass man sich
mit den abgrünzungsbeschlüssen nicht
noch mal beschäftigt hat gerade mit
Blick auf die Landtagswahlen die auch
anstehen
dass man immer noch die AFD also die in
drei Bundesländern mittlerweile als
gesichert rechtsextremistisch eingestuft
ist gleichsetzt mit einer linken halte
ich für einen absoluten Fehler
dass man das so festschreibt und fest
festgeschrieben lässt dann Herr Fogt der
Herr Linnemann unterstützt hat in diesem
Grundsatzprogramm
als türingens ne cduvorsit in Thüringen
und auchisterpräsentkandidat sicherlich
wird dann in die Verlegenheit kommen
wenn er keine Mehrheit bekommt und die
wird er sicherlich nicht bekommen wieder
so etwas wie ein Stabilitätspakt oder
stabilitätsabkommen mit den Linken zu
schließen und das wirkt sich auch wieder
erfahrungsgwes nicht unbedingt positiv
auf die klauwürdigkeit einer Partei aus
was wäre denn was wäre Ihrer Meinung
nach ein gutes Signal gewesen oder was
was W eine richtige Antwort darauf
gewesen es gab ja bei der letzten
Landtagswahl schon Bestrebung dass es
eine Annäherung zwischen Linke und CDU
gibt um eine stabile Verzeigung
Regierung auf den Weg zu bringen aber da
führte keinen Weg rein und ob man da
nicht unter gewissen politischen äh oder
vielleicht auch mit Blick auf die
Mehrheiten die möglich sind Ausnahmen zu
machen für einzelne Landesverbände und
dort nicht dann irgendwelche Brücken
bemühen zu müssen mm her frei also zwei
Punkte die mir dazu einfallen also
erstens wir sprechen über ein
Grundsatzprogramm und nicht über ein
Wahlprogramm und selbverständlich das
will ich ganz dezidiert sagen gehört S
grsatzfrage mit der
AFD diese Frage haben wir doch geklärt
da haben wir auch als Fraktion
entsprechende Beschlüsse gefast nein
Grundsatz großen Unterschied zwischen AF
wenn wir 70seitiges Grundsatzprogramm
machen dann sollten wir uns auch mit den
Grundsätzen beschäftigen und solche
Fragen klären wir in Wahl Programm und
der zweite Punkt ist der ähm ich sehe da
auch inhaltlich kein Versäumnis also
wenn Sie eine Koalition machen wollen
dann brauchen Sie eine inhaltliche
Schnittmenge und wir haben keine
inhaltliche Schnittmenge mit einer
sozialistischen Partei also so einfach
ist es es kann sein dass es schwierige
Konstellationen mehrheitskonstellationen
gibt dann braucht man dafür eine
pragmatische Herangehensweise aber eine
Koalition mit den Linken würde ich immer
ausschließen und zwar unabhängig davon
ob so etwas in dem Grundsatzprogramm
steht oder sonst irgendwo oder eben
nicht ja also das ist immer die Frage
ist das ein pragmatisches pragmatischer
Vorgehen sie können doch keine Koalition
in einer einer pluralistischen
Demokratie machen mit einer Partei mit
der sie keine schnittme wenn die
Alternative aber dann ist dass die AFD
dann
regiert das wäre ja nicht die
Alternative sie sehen ja gerade in
Thüring das ist natürlich überhaupt
nicht schön das zeugt auch nicht von
Stabilität das ist ja überhaupt keine
Frage und trotzdem in dieser Situation
wie wir sie dort haben würden wir doch
mit der linke keine Koalition bilden was
sollten wir denn für eine Politik mit
denen umsetzen ich würde ihnen übrigens
wiedersprechen und ich hoffe sie haben
Unrecht dass sie keine Schnittmengen mit
der Linken haben ich finde die in vielen
Punkten unsympatisch aber der
Unterschied z.B zwischen der linken und
der AFD ist insbesondere der Linken in
Thüringen die Linke ist eine sauber
dememokratische Partei und die AFD ist
insbesondere in thürungen eine
rechtsradikale Partei und das ist ein
großer Unterschied und sie haben deshalb
durchaus inhaltliche Schnittmengen mit
der Linken
n das beides sind demokratische Parteien
oder wenn sie davor gesprochen haben
unsere Werte nämlich wenn Sie unsere
Werte wie sie es vorher definiert haben
als Bekenntnis zum Grundgesetz teilen
die teilt die Linke in Thüringen und die
AFD in Thüringen eindeutig nicht des
auch total widersprü her h noch mal kurz
dazu Herr hol dazu noch mal ganz kurz
genau die AFD hat z.B auf dem letzten
Landesparteitag angekündigt aus dem
medienstaatsvertrag auszuscheiden oder
auszutreten diesen auchz kündigen falls
Sie hier die absolute Mehrheit bekommen
könnte nicht ganz
realistisches aber auch ein mögliches
Szenario sollten es grün und FDP hier
nicht in den Landtag schaffen dann wäre
solche so eine Sendung wie heute auch
schwierig ne also über sowas muss man
sich einfach Gedanken machen wenn man
über diese abgrenzungsbeschlüsse spricht
und ich finde es bleibt dabei es esind
versäunis okay aber dann nehmen wir das
einfach mal auf frei das Programm
darüber muss ja noch diskutiert werden
und wird auch abgestimmt werden also wie
viel Änderungsmöglichkeiten gibt's da
noch überhaupt da gibt viele
Änderungsmöglichkeiten jetzt wird
erstmal einen Monat der Bundesvorstand
sich mit dem Thema beschäftigen und dann
in die Partei auf den Weg bringen und im
Mai werden wir ein Bundesparteitag haben
der das Diskutieren wird das heißt die
Partei hat auch monatelang Zeit darüber
zu diskutieren okay gut dann haben wir
heute hier ein Anfang gemacht vielen
Dank Herr freif Frau quadbecker Holz
nach Erfurt und Herr Hofreiter vielen
dank ihnen für zuschauen morgen sind wir
wieder für Sie da und vielleicht gibt's
ja dann auch ein Ergebnis um beim
Haushaltsstreit wir reden mit jungen
Vertretern von verschiedenen Parteien
dann was dabei rauskommt oder eben noch
nicht dabei rausgekommen ist bis dahin
[Musik]
tschüss